medical advisor at the UK Health
Security Agency hi it's good to see you
Susan thanks for joining us can I just
check first of all it's not immediately
clear is this the first time this strain
of bird flu has been discovered in
humans
and no it's not so first of all we
detected a case in the United Kingdom in
December 2019 uh in an individual who
worked closely with Breads and poetry as
well and there have been many other
detections across the world of various
different types of bird flu but this
specific strain
approximately 10 detections have
resulted in cases in humans
what's the difference between bird flu
being detected in someone and actually
being infected by the disease
well I think you know as we know from
what we've experienced in the last few
years people with infection usually
manifest symptoms
um and uh and in bird flu many of the
cases who manifest symptoms have had
severe disease uh for those who've been
detected and there was a similar um a
detection and a farm in Spain last year
as well in those that were working with
poultry what we know is that we detect
it they remain as asymptomatic it is
very difficult to then understand
whether they have detected it because
they've been closely working in the
environment or whether we've detected
because the virus is replicating in
their nose that's something we're trying
to understand better and it's the reason
why the surveillance is so important
um how avian flu transfer to humans
well like with many viruses it can
transmit in in three main ways one is
through droplets where the the
transmission
can come from the air from close contact
second is from a longer Airborne
transmission and the third is from
fomites so contact with contaminated
material hands clothing environment can
allow to transmit
and once humans have this disease
um virus
um can they transfer it to other humans
well so actually we have not confirmed
human to human Transmissions globally uh
for this virus right now that's really
important it's one of the things that
we're monitoring very carefully because
if there was human to human transmission
that would increase the risk to the
population
um at present time there have been no
confirmed cases of human to human
transmission even in any cases that
there has been individuals have had the
same exposure to the environment or
infected animals or Birds how worried
should we be about this
so we still say that the risk to the
general population in the UK and uh
globally is low we have not increased
our risk level and we're monitoring our
risk levels and have published our risk
levels
on an ongoing basis and so uh We've
defined six risk levels and we remain at
risk level three this does not change
this
okay um you seemed pretty relaxed about
it
I think we are really happy that we've
got active surveillance we're really
thankful and grateful for the poultry
workers who are participating in this
surveillance because it helps us
understand it better and detect any
changes that might occur from Human case
detections or infections but we are not
seeing any risk of human to human
transmission at this time and we will
continue to monitor it it's great to see
you thanks for joining us
thank you